we have a president who was elected
after trafficking in barely barely
cloaked racial animus and so we're
seeing a lot of other people who are in
many ways mimicking this type of
language this country is a direct
byproduct of how Donald Trump behaves
the things that you that point the
things that he does not condemn and we
have to stop pretending that this
president has nothing to do with it that
he's not emboldened racist and racism
and giving them a platform and making it
okay
Richard could see his lawyer who advised
both of Hillary Clinton's presidential
campaigns he joins us tonight Richard I
I don't begrudge any political party or
it's surrogates in the media you know
the opportunity to grab an advantage
when you see one but on the subject of
the tweets which no normal person would
defend they're awful why the impulse to
immediately make it a partisan political
issue when there's a human message in
this conversation we just don't attack
people on the basis of their of their
race not like it's that simple why they
impulse to make it partisan certainly
what Roseanne Barr did was pathetic not
just to say it but then to blame it on
ambien remember she also said it was
Memorial Day I mean it was and this is
somebody who had said the exact same
thing about Susan Rice who had basically
defended the whole set thrist I mean the
tweet was bad I'm there all right you
know actually there are people I suspect
who actually are you know kind of
joining to her defense right oh this is
somehow her First Amendment rights are
being what I'm saying is look for most
of my adult life the senior Democrat in
the United States Senate was a former
Klan recruiter okay Robert Byrd a lot of
things named after Robert Byrd I'm not
even attacking Robert Byrd he apologized
but like let's get a little proportion
here the outrage is selective I'm not
defending the Roseanne crap but I also
think when people are jumping up and
down and being like actually Trump did
this it's purely political let's be
honest yes so actually I think that
people who don't subscribe to your view
believe the following the Donald Trump
has given license to people by saying
they're good Nazis by mocking
handicapped people by basically you know
the list is endless
handicapped oh sure
went like this about that New York Times
reports me mocking all handicapped
people he was mocking that guy that's
pathetic
that may be the single most pathetic
thing that he's done and he talked about
Mexicans being racist look the list is
on and on the fact of the matter is
though when Donald Trump does that and
people say well he won so his staff can
go will I can mimic people I can make
fun of John McCain who's dying I can you
know that's the problem then some people
who were supporters think at his rallies
you've heard people who covered in this
rally said these people were lovely and
then the rally would start and they
would say the most anti-semitic for
twenty years through Democrat and
Republican administrations and the
volume and the nastiness the hate mail I
received remains pretty much constant I
didn't blame Obama for the attack side
of the death threats I got five years I
mean let's just be totally real here
it's not look I understand you don't
like Trump but this is a much larger
question and part of the question is do
people who are engaging in racism like
Al Sharpton have the right to lecture
the rest of us about racism do they is
that Sharpton the spokesman you want
against racism no he's not oh okay I
agree with you but I do think that it is
undeniable that the fact that Donald
Trump spews what he did on the campaign
trail and his president to talk about
good Nazis it's something that sends a
signal like I basically of drawing
succor from these people and it's why he
he tweets about every stupid thing under
what NFL players kneeling I get a coach
is draw me in it's like defending every
dumb Trump tweet which I'm not no
interest in doing I want to talk about
the universal principles here okay so
we're against racism I hope I certainly
and we do a lot of shows on it course is
it wrong to discriminate against people
on the basis of their skin color well so
that's a different you're talking about
affirmative action oh I'm actually
talking about racism is it wrong to
discriminate against people on the basis
of their skin color and if it's not then
why do we care what Roseanne said but if
it is I understand why we're upset right
because you shouldn't attack people on
the basis of immutable characteristics
right do you agree with that I think the
Roseanne Barr and people like her talk
about black people that's all wrong I
agree with that completely I think
that's disgusting but what's the
principle is it wrong to discriminate
against someone on the basis of a skin
color too
hold him back to penalise when the base
of his skin it's a really simple
question can you answer it of course but
you're acting like somehow slavery
didn't happen I'm not saying that well
that's not the intimation of what you're
getting why would it because that's what
you know no no I'm not getting it that
I'm I'm a very straightforward person
yeah I say what I mean
and please don't attack me I'm asking
you about a principle right which is is
it wrong to hurt people to hold them
back deny them things that would
otherwise get because of their race it's
a really simple question yes or no I
agree that people should not be
denominated again I'm saying they should
not be discriminate against the race but
we don't have a colorblind society Eric
Holder and other black cabinet officials
have a trouble hailing a taxi cab I'm
not denying that I'm merely saying is it
wrong to practice racism as people oh it
is yes so you would say it's totally
wrong to say to a child because of your
skin color we're holding you back
there's a massive lawsuit against
Harvard right now by Asian students who
have basically proven that Harvard
didn't let them in because of their race
right is that okay with you you used to
be subjected to the exact same thing it
was wrong right but liberals support it
now right so those people lecture me
about racism
are you joking the Harvard argument is
that there's a certain virtue in
diversity oh there's a virtue and
discrimination because versity no I'm
calling it what it is because we both
agreed that penalizing people on the
basis of their race is immoral you
agreed with that and yet it's happening
right now with the full support of
liberals the same ones who are lecturing
the rest of us about racism right it's
too much and I'm saying there's a quilt
involved and there's yes discriminate
against people on the basis of their
skin color is wrong let's stop it
basically but but people were held back
for hundreds of years
and to basically act like that didn't
happen but I'm not acting like it didn't
happen I'm not saying I think it's the
central sin of America yeah I think it's
our original sin I think it's terrible
but I don't think that racism is okay
and liberals do and I just want to be
clear and I want our viewers to
understand that is the official position
of the Democratic Party is that hurting
people on the basis of the race is a-ok
no the visitors of the Democratic Party
is that we have to take cognizance of
the fact that what happened for
two hundred years and if we act like it
didn't happen and that somehow other
regions point in life that we know we
know act like skin color doesn't matter
that is is that is normal so the Chinese
kid who arrived here 20 minutes ago
right suffers for that right because of
his race no question that's okay no the
Democrats the same ones giving us
lectures during their anti racism
summits yeah yeah as I said I think what
the Chinese students are arguing about
in Harvard has merit as it did for the
Jews with them yeah I hope so
I am thank you Richard go see it sure